there's a lot of things that we know now
that should they should have taught us
as a kid yeah right I think the number
one thing is you don't have to have a
regular job
yeah when you were a kid when high
school I remember we had um some career
like there was a like they would career
counselors okay and you had to go in and
they look at your grades and they go um
we think you should be this
you know it's always wood shop with me
I don't know what that meant but like or
metal work wow I don't know how to use
anything I don't think they're wrong
about that why I think you're so good
with your hands and making things all
right nice but I think that but I go but
I remember looking at ago is there any
other option and they're like that's it
and then I remember years of going oh
man I'm gonna be a carpenter or whatever
right and then I realized now no you can
do whatever I'll tell fart jokes yeah
yeah yeah right like they never pop in
high school they ever said oh you'll be
you could be a rapper yeah no I grew up
in a town Rochester Minnesota which is
where the Mayo Clinic is which is like
the biggest Hospital in America and so
you mean by biggest in terms of size I
think most employees and like most you
know
renowned and like yeah people will
there's a lot of people what's it called
the Mayo Clinic you've never heard
you've probably like looked up if you
had like a weird like thing going on you
want to look up symptoms It's usually
the first result
for like a lot of stuff and Mayo Clinic
Mayo Clinic like mayonnaise yeah yeah
yeah never heard I went to Mayo High
School
um but people would there'd be a lot of
people in my hometown that were from you
know it was like Saudi Arabian princes
and like damn people from Mad different
countries because only that hospital has
like the equipment to
to treat certain rare oh that's
interesting anyways everybody was in the
medical fields and my mom is retired now
she was a psychiatrist and my dad was a
psychologist like studying insomnia
so I just oh okay I just thought I was
gonna end up going into like medicine or
something or I thought I was gonna end
up going to college for eight or 12
years or something uh and then when I
went to college I started with physics
and I tried biology and I hated all that
and I switched up to a bunch of
different things and then
I ended up in business and that's when I
like I started as a business kid and
then like but I loved hip-hop and then
I just realized like yo I was starting
other little businesses and I thought oh
why don't I just make myself or your
parents because they're both Physicians
where they're like come on Matthew okay
so well first of all my dad died when I
was 16 so I hadn't even thought about
being a rapper yet
sorry it's all good thank you you close
to him pretty close oh my God he was
born he's born in Switzerland he's much
much older than how old was dads well
when I was 16 and he passed he was
17 almost about to turn 80. whoa wait
that's like me yeah her dad was sick me
Theo you yeah yeah Theo has I think he
he flexed on me because his dad was
actually older than mine wait when was
your because my dad was born in 1924.
well wow wow
I'm 38. okay okay so it's kind of the
same difference I'm I'm 27 my dad was
born in 1933. wow oh I think you had me
beat yeah yeah apparently but yeah yeah
you're good at math because I had to
really think about that that was a guess
okay but wow that's crazy that's insane
my mom is
66 I believe now so they had a big gap
see my my parents had a 36 year age
our mine's 23 I thought that was a lot
I'm 21. but it's 36. yeah so six how
old's your mom he's 62 now so but in
2003 my dad died when he was 80. that
was in 2003. wow we have a very similar
was Monday I mean was about to turn 80.
yeah in 2013. everything is just I
always think old sperm makes the
weirdest funniest kids like Josh Peck I
think same thing yeah
um that's why I've been that's why I
don't have children now
because when I'm I'm gonna do it when
I'm later like Larry yeah I want to make
funny kids I want to do that too A lot
of my good friends have a lot of my
really good friends have really old
parents wait till you're sick in your
60s then